after 4 years I finally got around to
tidying my office well almost anyway
behold my stuff I got a little too into
god of war and bought a replica of the
Leviathan axe it even has my name on it
in runic style I can't decide if that's
cool or extremely sad anyway I think it
looks amazing the weirdest statue in my
collection is this crypto from Destroy
All Humans when the remaster released
this guy was in the collector's edition
and now it sits in my room probably the
coolest thing I own is venom snakes
bionic arm from Metal Gear Solid 5 the
one to1 scale didn't release in the UK
so I had to import this from Japan the
paint job is made to look battle scarred
and all the digits here are articulated
so it holds my controller on a daily
basis but sometimes I come into my room
and it's been changed to this hm